in a dance with dragons and season 5 of
Game of Thrones a night called Robert
strong appears in King's Landing
Qyburn brings him to Cersei to join the
Kingsguard and to fight for her in her
upcoming trial by combat where Cersei
stands accused of treason so strong has
apparently taken a vow of silence
swearing not to speak until all his
Grace's enemies are dead and evil has
been driven from the realm he doesn't
show his face or take off his armor he
apparently doesn't eat or drink or use
the Privy and he's huge eight feet tall
or maybe taller where did this man come
from asks mace Tyrell why have we never
heard his name before is he even really
a knight who or what is this silent
giant to answer these questions we need
to turn to Qyburn when we first meet
Qyburn he seems nice enough he's
described as fatherly and grandfatherly
with warm brown eyes but he's actually
an incredibly sketchy dude
Coburn serves the leech Lord Roose
Bolton at the notoriously cursed castle
of Harrenhal and before that he rides
with an infamous cell sword company the
brave companions also called the bloody
mummies Carbone himself has a reputation
for black magic and necromancy having
been kicked out of the Citadel for
opening the bodies of the living to
better understand the nature of death
the show suggests he performed dangerous
and unnatural experiments on living men
in any case he's a skilled healer so
Coburn treats Jaime's hand or stomp and
comes with him to King's Landing there
he wins the trust of Cersei whoo
confides in him tells him her dreams and
her secrets at a time when she feels
alone and threatened so she makes Qyburn
master of whisperers after Varys
disappears with Tyrion according to
Roose Bolton
Qyburn hopes to be made a maester again
and in the show Kevin calls Clyburn a
sycophant Coburn has cleverly gained the
favor of Cersei and a seat on the small
Council but it's not like he just wants
power Coburn tells Jaime in the show
that his weakness is curiosity he's a
sort of a medieval mad scientist talking
of proof and reason and performing bold
experiments out of a genuine passion for
unlocking the secrets of the body in the
show he tells Jaime that the inside
from his studies has saved many lives
but as Cersei says Qyburn can do Horrors
as well as wonders
Qyburn shows an interest in the mountain
gregor clegane who has been wounded by
Oberyn Martell's poisoned spear and his
dying of the venom slowly and an
exquisite agony Cersei wants to put the
Mad Dog down but Qyburn convinces her to
let him tend to Gregor instead in the
books he's very vague about what he
plans to do with the mountain just
implies it's related to life and death
and the Black Arts in the show
Coburn told Cersei that he's saving
Gregor in a process that will change him
somewhat but not weaken him
Cersei supports this work she provides
gold and she also gives Qyburn people
mostly women who so she wants to get rid
of the handmaiden Sanel some puppeteers
and fully Stokeworth
Brahms wife sister we don't know what
Qyburn does with these women in his
dungeon but we do know Sanel is
exhausted the puppeteers are used up and
Felice is not entirely comfortable and
no longer capable of feeding herself
before she dies screaming this all seems
to be related to Gregor who remains with
Qyburn screaming in the darkness of the
dungeon or in the show creepily moving
beneath a sheet in fire burns lab before
Cersei is arrested by the high Sparrow
Qyburn promises to produce a champion
who will protect Cersei son kill her
enemies and keep her secrets someone who
no living man will be able to withstand
he also orders a suit of armor so heavy
that the armor says no man is strong
enough to move and fight in it after
Sosa's arrest carbone visit so she in
her cell and in the show he says the
work continues shortly after we meet
Robert strong so in summary a freakishly
big Knight is dying a necromancer uses
him in creepy experiments then produces
a freakishly big knight who doesn't seem
completely normal or alive it's pretty
obvious that Sir Robert strong is Sir
Gregor Clegane somehow reanimated or
kept alive or Frankenstein's together
from the parts of Kai burns victims an
eight-foot-tall undead Mountain Gregor
Clegane has probably dealt more death
and destruction with his own hands than
any other man in Westeros Doran Martell
says if ever a man deserved to die
screaming
it was Gregor Clegane
and with the rise of Robert strong
Gregor might just die twice some may
call that justice but maybe we should
pity gregor clegane we find out in face
that Gregor habitually drank some milk
of the poppy to dull the pain of
blinding headaches it may be that
Gregor's extreme brutality ultimately
comes from pain physical and maybe
emotional like this man is so [ __ ] up
that he can only find respite from pain
by inflicting it so isn't there
something cruel in prolonging his
suffering by raising him from the dead
in the show carbon is at Harrenhal when
Gregor puts the placed a sword
so maybe Qyburn resents Gregor and
enjoys having him as his twisted
plaything
it's ugly however you looked at it
someone needs to end this silent night
the question is who who will represent
the faith by fighting Roberts wrong in
Sosa's trial to some the obvious choice
is someone like Lancel Lannister who
would probably be obliterated by so
strong but there's another theory that
the supposedly dead gregor clegane will
fight another supposedly dead Clegane
Sandor the Hound this is called
cleganebowl and is tradition so what it
basically does is combine the idea that
Robert strong is Gregor Clegane with the
gravedigger theory that Sandor Clegane
is still alive we won't get into
gravedigger here but basically there's a
lot of good evidence that the Hound
survives the wounds that nearly kill him
and becomes a monk on a secluded island
Clegane bold claims that the faith in
King's Landing bring the Hound out of
this retirement and set him to one last
fight to kill his brother the man he's
hated all his life the man who's been
brutally killing and raping across the
realm for years it may be that like the
White Walkers White's the undead Gregor
has a weakness to fire the Hound has a
fear of fire ever since Gregor gave
sandal his burns
maybe the Hound will overcome this fear
and use fire to kill his abominable
brother in an act of violent redemption
these are two of the greatest warriors
in Westeros returned from the dead to
fight for the fate of Cersei Lannister
before all King's Landing cleganebowl
would be pretty [ __ ] sick and a lot
of people would love to
happen however there's no strong or
direct evidence that it will happen and
there are a lot of good reasons to
believe it won't for starters it
wouldn't really fit the character arc of
Sandor who has let go of violence and
hatred he's embraced a life of peace as
a monk a crippled monk who no one even
knows is still alive apart from the
elder brother who keeps his identity
secret on a remote island george RR
martin has crafted this beautiful
conclusion to Sandor story and it just
doesn't fit to have him kill again even
for a good cause
soca gained bold doesn't seem likely in
the books but HBO does seem willing to
sacrifice some character development if
it means they can fit in a few more
flashy fights as with Jaime and a recent
casting announcement suggests that the
next season will feature Septon mera
bald the guy who takes Brienne to quiet
Isle where she sees the gravedigger who
is probably Sandor which seems weird
with the show spend screen time on sound
or unless they plan to use him for
something HBO is probably more aware of
than receptive to the Game of Thrones
fandom than George's who says he doesn't
raid theories and writes his books on a
computer that isn't even connected to
the internet so maybe just maybe even if
Clegane ball doesn't happen in the books
it could happen in the show if HBO knows
viewers wanted perhaps someone needs to
tell them regardless the evidence shows
that the mountain rides again that sir
Robert strong is a reanimated Gregor
Clegane zombie and whoever he fights
it'll be really cool to see how this
story plays out in seasons and books to
come thanks for watching as ever check
out the Song of Ice and Fire subreddit
and Westeros org and all the other great
communities where Game of Thrones
theories originate and are discussed you
can check out the gravedigger video if
you'd like to see the evidence that's
handle cocaine still lives you can also
subscribe to and follow all chip decks
for more explanations and analysis both
on Game of Thrones and some other stuff
coming soon Cheers